si vous pensez que ça ne peut pas empirer, c'est possible
et ce sera le cas,
les mourants n'ont pas été commis, les meurtres n'ont pas été
commis, j'ai promis à mon équipage il y a longtemps de
les garder en vie à la
maison, j'avais peur que vous soyez mort, où est le
reste du troisième peloton dans lequel
nous sommes Sergent  Collier, je suis ton nouveau
chauffeur adjoint de l'école de chars qui est à la maison, je
ne m'ai même jamais vu à l'intérieur du char, tu le
feras.
J'ai commencé cette guerre en tuant des Allemands en
Afrique, maintenant je tue des Allemands en
Allemagne, alors avec ces braves messieurs,
quatre ans,
ces troupes pourraient bien t'acheter.  mort dans
l'eau oh on nous a toi je veux
te demander de faire tout ce que je n'ai pas fait moi-même
vérifier les communications je vais Tek super projet de merde
et les anguilles sont paisibles l'
histoire est violente
pourquoi vois-tu voir ce que nous sommes manga
griffonner un autre homme
qui est  J'ai peur pour eux que cela se termine
bientôt avant que cela ne se produise, beaucoup plus de gens
doivent mourir, nous savons que nous recevons un dollar
trente-cinq par jour, c'est vrai, ce travail, très bien, allons de l'
avant
Chris Joe chaque fois qu'ils
arrivent, combien d'entre eux sont 300
cette fibre obtient 300, tu ne courras jamais
avant alors que nous allons courir maintenant nous sommes
toujours dans ce combat